[Musique]
la première fois que je suis allé au
lido je devais avoir
une trentaine d'années même pas voilà et
donc et moi j'ai trouvé ça
grandiose j'ai trouvé ça je sais ça que
je veux faire c'est voilà j'ai toujours
aimé
sublimer la femme
[Musique]
moi je connaisse pas trop ce qu'est ce
que c'est c'est le plus mais tous donc
j'étais allé voir son atelier et l'a dit
me dis un truc qui m'a interpellé ça n'a
pas l'air compliqué alors j'aime pas
trop qu'on me dit ça quand même et dans
l'ubaye cei et c'est ce qu'il a fait il
a réalisé une structure de spectacle je
me rappellerai ma vie en rose et blanc
et c'était une pure merveille d'ailleurs
gelé vendus dans les quinze jours conçu
et là je me dis qu'elle beaucoup
il faut un don pour ça il ya il faut une
certaine dextérité il faut énormément de
patience parce que la plume c'est
quelque chose de volatiles une porte
s'ouvre ça peut être faudrait tout votre
travail en l'air
[Musique]
la relève est là et c'est tant mieux on
est reparti pour dix ans au moins
j'espère au moins qu'ils ne changent de
cap mais je ne pense pas que ça lui
plaît énormément et a jamais eu autant
de plumes différentes dans la maison
[Musique]
là